Like it or not it's rhythm's game
now i've always loved a little puzzle
what are we looking for more symbols jesus victim
is bruce wayne it can be cruel poetic or blind
but when it's denied it's your violence you
may find the answer's justice i'm sorry
i wouldn't be bothering you here but your
people keep telling me you're unavailable
you know you really could
be doing more for this city
my family has a history of philanthropy
but as far as i can tell you're not doing
anything if i'm elected i want
to change that thank you my god
i'm gonna go pay my respects will
you wait for me i want to continue
excuse me chief here to talk to you
gil coulson is missing what he hasn't been heard
from since last night not again hey mr wayne
you got people looking for him jim
send a couple guys to his house
nothing what did his wife say she hadn't heard
get back down
get out
get them up get out show up
christ it's colson there's a bomb
let's clear this place out now
the batman greedy pg-13.
Welcome back everyone
this is my new batman trailer video there's a
bunch of new footage to break down a bunch
of easter eggs so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we'll do a giveaway for movie tickets all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and just leave
your favorite moment from the trailer on the video
i'll start with the new trailer scenes then i'll
talk about batman's no kill rule because as you've
noticed from some of the previous trailers it
actually looks like there's a scene of batman
almost killing riddler and catwoman kind of
freaking out like oh my god he's gonna kill
this guy but in the new trailer scenes gordon and
the police learn that riddler's next victim is
going to be bruce wayne it's probably a little
bit later in the movie after riddler's already
killed a couple of the major characters like the
mayor and gil coulson early theory too gil coulson
the district attorney when the movie starts is the
person who has the job before harvey dent gets the
job because part of the story of the batman movie
is inspired by the long halloween and that story
is a harvey dent two-face origin story but unless
matt raves is pulling a fast one on us harvey dent
is not a character in this first new batman movie
maybe it'll be some easter eggs for him but it
sounds like they're setting things up to introduce
him in one of the sequels where they'll do a new
version of a two-faced origin story because matt
reeves said one of his big reasons for setting
this batman franchise so early in batman's career
is so that he could do origin stories for a lot of
the classic rogues gallery of villains issues that
in this first movie riddler penguin and catwoman
are the biggest ones they've been hyping in all
the trailers the new scene here with riddler's
collage they're looking at that contains all
these clues linking all of his victims it's
meant to be all the powerful people in gotham that
he's targeting in the movie or has already killed
when they're seeing this it's meant to be a more
complicated version of this flow chart drawn on
the floor this one just has a bunch of newspaper
clippings with headlines in the riddler's riddles
and notes written all over it these two things
are meant to show how his victims are connected
it's just that the one on the floor here does
a better job of visualizing that in a lot of
his broadcasts he does have a sort of manifesto
that he parcels out talking about justice and
a lot of his riddles like his justice riddle if
it's denied its violence you may find he's kind
of slowly explaining why he's doing everything
in his messages to batman like alfred says why
is he writing to you early theory based on a
lot of the other scenes is because he's figured
out that bruce wayne is batman and they have a
connection going back to their childhood which
i'll talk about in a second but all these victims
here you can see the dawn here is the mayor who
he's already killed at the beginning of the film
gill coulson the district attorney who we see him
kill or get ready to kill during this scene at the
mayor's funeral carmine falcone who he may also
wind up killing during the film pete savage is
the current police commissioner before gordon gets
the job he's on the flow chart on the floor here
then thomas wayne his father bruce wayne is also
named here and he also separately calls out batman
because when the riddler first puts his plan into
action it's already batman year two so the riddler
in preparing his plan over the course of a year
has been watching batman run around gotham going
after criminals for the entirety of batman year
one so after watching him for a year he probably
slowly puts the clues together and figures out
that he is bruce wayne that also makes me feel
like this is giving off some hush vibes too
because during the batman hush storyline riddler
is pulling a lot of strings after he figures out
batman's secret identity but if it wasn't clear
from the earlier trailers or my other videos the
common theme linking all these people that the
riddler is trying to get rid of is that he sees
them as the true villains in gotham the corrupt
political figures other corrupt powerful people
like a powerful elite group who are doing all
these bad things or as the riddler sees it
not doing the right things to make gotham city
better and that connects with the funeral scene
where this woman here is talking to him about how
he should be doing more philanthropy your father
gave a lot of money he did a lot of charity for
gotham but you are not so the riddler's kind of
calling bruce wayne batman out for not going after
the real criminals like you shouldn't be going
after all these street level thugs these low-level
gangs that you're beating up in the rain here you
need to be going after the true villains in gotham
the connection between the riddler in batman bruce
wayne that goes back to their childhood and the
reason why riddler would be calling out thomas
wayne gets into the gotham city orphanage there's
a bunch of pictures of them as children together
this is riddler as a child but you also see bruce
wayne standing next to him with thomas and martha
wayne standing next to all the children and it
just sounds like something really bad happened
to the riddler as a child in the gotham city
orphanage and he either blames thomas wayne
for that or he blames him for not helping when
he could have that might have something to do
with the scenes where you see bruce wayne
talking to alfred about lying to him you've
been lying to me alfred it probably has something
to do with something his father did or did not do
and it just seems like they're trying to draw
this connection between them as children and
what happened with the gotham city orphanage then
getting to the no kill rule so like i said there's
the scene of him almost killing riddler and
obviously he probably does not wind up killing him
because robert pattinson made this big deal about
his no kill rule so this is what robert pattinson
actually said i'm just paraphrasing him he said
there is this rule with batman he must not kill
it can be interpreted in two ways either he
only wants to inflict the appropriate punishment
or he wants to kill and his self-control prevents
him from doing so he goes on to say that when they
were working on some of the fight scenes the way
he imagined it he said there's something in him
talking about something inside batman that wanted
to slit this guy's throat he says i told myself if
batman spends his nights chasing criminals it's
impossible that he does not take pleasure in it
so this is probably going to be one of the most
vicious most raw versions of batman that we've
seen in the movie even though ben affleck's batman
did kill people like you talk about the no kill
rule and they actually just had a big joke about
that on the dc peacemaker series i did a video
about that so i'll link it in the description
below you see batman doesn't kill people because
he's a he's a dark creature of the night he's a
jackass when it comes to batman's no kill rule
it really just depends on how people interpret
that different writers or different directors
in different movies like michael keaton's batman
is probably the deadliest batman he probably has
the highest kill count of any live-action version
of batman so far but they also just released a new
synopsis for the film which just kind of helps
clarify some of the things that are going on and
some of the relationships between the characters
it says two years of stalking the streets as
batman striking fear into the hearts of criminals
has led bruce wayne deep into the shadows of
gotham city with only a few trusted allies amongst
the city's corrupt network of officials and
high-profile figures like alfred pennyworth james
gordon the lone vigilante has established himself
as the sole embodiment of vengeance amongst his
fellow citizens matt reeves said that there are
a lot of people in gotham because this is still
pretty early in his career who don't totally trust
him they think that he's either a myth or they're
just flat out afraid of him like they think of him
as a crazy man running around in a back costume
just beating people up in the middle of the night
he hasn't really reached iconic status like the
older versions of batman later in his career then
the synopsis says when a killer targets gotham's
elite with a series of sadistic machinations a
trail of cryptic clues sends the world's greatest
detective on an investigation to the underworld
where he encounters such characters as selena kyle
catwoman oswald cobblepop penguin carmine falcone
and edward nashton aka the riddler as the evidence
begins to lead closer to home and the scale of the
perpetrator's plans become clear batman must
forge new relationships unmask the culprit
and bring justice to the abuse of power and
corruption that has long played gotham city
but if you spotted any other easter eggs in the
trailer that i didn't talk about in the video
or my previous trailer videos just write them
below in the comments there'll be more batman
trailers before the movie comes out it's
not coming out to the beginning of march
my peacemaker episode 5 video in my star wars book
of boba fett episode 5 video will both post this
week just like normal make sure you have alert
sample for my channel so you don't miss anything
there's a bunch of other really big stuff coming
up too and we have a bunch of super bowl trailers
that will be dropping in the next couple of weeks
everyone click here for my brand new marvel moon
night trailer video and everyone click here for
my eternals black panther 2 easter egg video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!